but you have spoken about
agi and the existential risks around it
and sort of based on your intuition that
we're quite far away from
that being a serious concern relative to
the other concepts we have
can you maybe uh unpack that a little
bit yeah sure
so so as as i understand it that
uh for example i read boston's book and
a bunch of other
reading material about this sort of
general way of thinking about the world
and
i think the story goes something like
this that we
will at some point create computers that
uh are smart enough that they can help
design the next version of themselves
which itself will be smarter than the
previous version of themselves and
eventually bootstrapped up to being
smarter
than us at which point we
are essentially at the mercy of this
sort of more powerful intellect
which in principle uh
we don't have any control over what its
goals are and so if its goals
are at all out of sync with our goals
like the ex for example the continued
existence of humanity
we won't be able to stop it it'll be way
more powerful
than us and we will be toast so
there's some i don't know very smart
people who have signed on to that story
and it's a
it's a compelling story i once
now i can really get myself in trouble i
once wrote an op-ed about this
specifically responding to some quotes
from elon musk who has been
you know on this very podcast uh more
than once
and well the e-e-a-i is summoning the
demon
this is something he said but then he
came to providence rhode island which is
where i live
and said uh to the governors of all the
states
uh you know you're worried about
entirely the wrong thing you need to be
worried about ai you need to be very
very worried about ai so uh and peop
journalists kind of reacted to that they
wanted to get people's people's take and
i was like okay
my my my belief is that one of the
things that makes elon musk
so successful and so remarkable as an
individual
is that he believes in the power of
ideas he believes that you can have you
can
if you know if you have a really good
idea for getting into space you can get
into space if you have a really good
idea for a company or for
how to change the way that people drive
you just have to do it and
and it can happen it's really natural to
apply that same idea to ai you see
these systems that are doing some pretty
remarkable computational
tricks demonstrations and then to take
that idea and just push it
all the way to the limit and think okay
where does this go where is this going
to take us next
and if you're a deep believer in the
power of ideas then
it's really natural to believe that
those ideas could be taken to the
extreme and
kill us so i think you know his strength
is also his
undoing because that doesn't mean it's
true like it doesn't mean that that has
to happen
but it's natural for him to think that
so
another way to phrase the way he thinks
and
i find it very difficult to argue with
that line of thinking
uh so sam harris is another person from
neuroscience perspective and things like
that
is saying well is there something
fundamental in the physics of the
universe
that prevents this from eventually
happening and this
negbostrom thinks in the same way
they're kind of zooming out
yeah okay we humans now uh are existing
in this
like time scale of minutes and days and
so our intuition is in this time scale
of
minutes hours and days but if you look
at the span of human history
is there any reason we you
can't see this in in 100 years and
like is there is there something
fundamental about the laws of physics
that prevent this
and if it doesn't then it eventually
will happen or we'll
we will destroy ourselves in some other
way it's very difficult
i find to actually argue against that
yeah
me too and not
sound like not sound like you're just
like rolling your ass uh i'm like i have
like science fiction we don't have to
think about it but even
even worse than that which is like i
don't know kids but like i gotta pick up
my kids now
like this okay i see there's more
pressing shortcuts yeah there's more
pressing short-term things that like
uh stop it with this existential crisis
where much much shorter things like
now especially this year there's cova so
like any kind of discussion like that is
like there's you know there's pressing
things
uh today it's it's and then so the sam
harris argument well
like any day the exponential singularity
can can occur it's very difficult to
argue against i mean i don't know but
part of his story is also
he's he's not gonna put a date on it it
could be in a thousand years it could be
in a hundred years it could be in two
years it's just that as long as we keep
making this kind of progress it's
ultimately
has to become a concern i i kind of am
on board with that but the thing that
the
piece that i feel like is missing from
that that way of extrapolating from the
moment that we're in
is that i believe that in the process of
actually developing technology that can
really get around in the world and
really process and and
and do things in the world in a
sophisticated way we're going to learn a
lot about
what that means which that we don't know
now because we don't know how to do this
right now
if you believe that you can just turn on
a deep learning network and eventually
give it enough compute and it'll
eventually get there well sure that
seems really scary because we won't we
won't be in the loop at all we want
we won't be helping to design or or
target these kinds of systems but i
don't i don't see
that that feels like it is against the
laws of physics because these systems
need help right they need
they need to surpass the the
the difficulty the wall of complexity
that happens in arranging something in
the form that
that will happen in yeah like i believe
in evolution
like i believe that the that that
there's an argument right so there's
another argument just to look at it from
a different
perspective that people say well i don't
believe in evolution how could evolution
it's it's sort of like a random set of
parts assemble themselves into a 747 and
that could just never happen
yeah so it's like okay that's maybe hard
to argue against but
clearly 747s do get assembled they get
assembled by us
basically the idea being that there's a
process by which we will get to the par
the point of making
technology that has that kind of
awareness and
in that process we're going to learn a
lot about that process and we'll have
more
ability to control it or to shape it or
to build it in our own image
it's not something that is going to
spring into existence like that 747
and we're just gonna have to contend
with it completely unprepared
now it's very possible that in the
context
of the long arc of human history it will
in fact spring into existence
but that springing might take like if
you look at nuclear weapons
like even 20 years is a springing
in in the context of human history and
it's very possible
just like with nuclear weapons that we
could have i don't know what percentage
you want to put at it but
the the possibility could have knocked
ourselves out yeah the possibility of
human
beings destroying themselves in the 20th
century with nuclear weapons
i don't know you can if you really think
through it you could really put it close
to like i don't know 30 40
given like the certain moments of crisis
that happened
so like i think one
like fear in the shadows that's not
being acknowledged
is this not so much the ai will run away
is
is that as it's running away we won't
have enough time to think through how to
stop
it right fast takeoff or foom yeah
i mean my much bigger concern i wonder
what you think about it which is
we won't know it's happening
uh so i kind of that argument i think
that there is an
agi situation already happening with
social media
that our minds our collective
intelligence of human civilization is
already being controlled by an algorithm
and like we're we're already super
like the the level of a collective
intelligence thanks to wikipedia people
should donate to wikipedia
to feed the agi man if we had a super
intelligence that
that was in line with wikipedia's values
that it's a lot better than a lot of
other things i can imagine i i
trust wikipedia more than i trust
facebook or youtube as far as
trying to do the right thing from a
rational perspective yeah now that's not
where you were going i understand that
but it
it does strike me that there's sort of
smarter and less smart ways of
of exposing ourselves to each other on
the internet
yeah the interesting thing is that
wikipedia and social media have very
different forces
you're right i mean wikipedia if if agi
was wikipedia he'd be
just like this cranky overly competent
editor of uh articles uh you know
there's there's something to that but
the social
media aspect is is is not
so the vision of agis is as a separate
system
that's super intelligent that's super
intelligent that's one key little thing
i mean there's the paperclip argument
that's super dumb
but super powerful systems but with
social media you have
a relatively like algorithms we may talk
about today
very simple algorithms that when
uh so something charles talks a lot
about which is interactive ai when they
start like
having at scale like tiny little
interactions with human beings
they can start controlling these human
beings so a single algorithm
can control the minds of human beings
slowly to where we might not
realize it can start wars it can start
it can change the way we
think about things it feels like in the
long arc of history
if i were to sort of zoom out from all
the outrage and all the tension on
social media
that it's progressing us towards better
and better things
it feels like chaos and toxic and all
that kind of stuff but
it's chaos and toxic yeah but it feels
like actually
the chaos and toxic is similar to the
kind of debates we had
from the founding of this country you
know there was a civil war that happened
over that over that period and
ultimately it was all about
this tension of like something doesn't
feel right about our implementation of
the core values we hold as
human beings and they're constantly
struggling with this and that results in
people calling each other uh like
just just being shitty to each other on
twitter
but i ultimately the algorithm is
managing all that and it feels like
there's a possible future in which that
algorithm
controls us to into the direction of
self-destruction and
whatever that looks like yeah so so all
right i do believe in the power of
social media to
screw us up royally i do believe in the
power of social media to benefit us too
i do think that we're in a
yeah it's sort of almost got dropped on
top of us and now we're trying to as a
culture
figure out how to cope with it
there's a sense in which i don't know
there's there's some arguments that say
that for example
uh i guess college-age students now late
college-age students now people who were
in middle school
when when social media started to really
take off
maybe maybe really damaged like me this
may have really hurt their development
in a way that we
don't have all the implications of quite
yet that's the generation who
if and i hate to make it somebody else's
responsibility but like they're the ones
who can fix it they're the ones who can
who can figure out
how do we keep the good of this kind of
technology without
letting it eat us alive and
if they're successful we move on to the
next
phase the next level of the game if
they're not successful then yeah then
we're going to wreck each other we're
going to
destroy society so you're going to in
your old age sit on the porch and watch
the world burn
because the tick tock generation that uh
i believe well so like this my kids age
right and that's certainly my daughter's
age and she's very tapped in
to social stuff but she's also she's
trying to find that balance right of
participating in it and then getting the
positives of it but without letting it
eat her
alive um and i think sometimes she
ventures
i hope she has to watch this sometimes i
think she ventures a little too far and
is
and is consumed by it and other times
she gets a little distant
um and if you know if there's enough
people like her out there they're gonna
they're gonna navigate this
this choppy waters that's that's an
interesting uh
skill actually to develop i talked to my
dad about it
you know i've now somehow
this podcast in particular but other
reasons
has received a little bit of attention
and with that
apparently in this world even though i
don't shut up about love and i'm just
all about kindness i i have now a little
mini
army of trolls oh it's kind of hilarious
actually
but it also doesn't feel good but it's a
skill to learn
to not look at that like to moderate
actually how much you look at that
the discussion i have with my dad is
similar to uh
it doesn't have to be about trolls it
could be about checking email which is
like if you're anticipating you know
there's uh my dad
runs a large institute at drexel
university and
there could be stressful like emails
you're waiting like there's drama of
some kind
and so like there's a temptation to
check the email
if you send an email you cut it and that
pulls you in
into it doesn't feel good and
it's a skill that he actually complains
that he hasn't learned i mean he
grew up without it so he hasn't learned
the skill of how to
shut off the internet and walk away and
i think young people
while they're also being quote unquote
damaged by like
uh you know being bullied online all
those stories which are very
like horrific you basically can't escape
your bullies
these days when you're growing up but at
the same time they're also learning that
skill of how to
be able to shut off uh the
like disconnect with it be able to laugh
at it not take it
too seriously it's fascinating like
we're all trying to figure this out just
like you said it's
been dropped on us and we're trying to
figure it out yeah i think that's really
interesting and i i
guess i've become a believer in the
human design
which i feel like i don't completely
understand like how do you make
something
as robust as us like we're so flawed in
so many ways and yet
and yet you know we dominate the planet
and
we do seem to manage to get ourselves
out of scrapes
eventually not necessarily the most
elegant possible way but somehow we get
we get to the next step
and i don't know how i'd make a machine
do that i
i i generally speaking like if i train
one of my reinforcement learning agents
to play a video game
and it works really hard on that first
stage over and over and over again and
it makes it through it succeeds on that
first level
and then the new level comes and it's
just like okay i'm back to the drawing
board and somehow humanity we keep
leveling up
and then somehow managing to put
together the skills necessary to
achieve success some semblance of
success in that next level too
and you know i hope we can keep doing
that
you